you
[Music]
okay thanks everyone for coming so it's
my pleasure to introduce sebastian
Rumaki from the TU Graz in Austria
Sebastian's been working with Melissa
and I for about the last year on a new
signature algorithm and he's on his way
to CCS to present the results next week
and so he's going to give us the talk
here today
so welcome Sebastian thank you like to
thank Greg for inviting me to stay here
a few days at Microsoft Research yeah so
um we're going to talk about signature
signature scheme today which is built
from sorry from symmetric key primitives
this is besides Melissa and Craig also
trying to work with Stephen cultivator
from Princeton Claudio and Andy from
ours University in Denmark and Kristian
and David from Q crowd and under semanek
from the Australian Institute of
Technology so um maybe short overview
but teacher signatures you mean it's you
usually have a signer with a public and
private key who can sign documents using
the the private key and then a verifier
verifies it using the public key and
checks if the signatures well it it's a
very it's used in many protocols today
from from certificate authorities in TLS
to a government use cases wherein a
person can identify its itself or many
of interest many applications but most
of the RSA and discrete logarithm based
signature schemes are become insecure in
in a world where we consider posed in a
quantum adversary this is tutus Shaw
algorithm from 1994
so new Sigma scheme have been built
based on
new structures hardness assumptions from
lattices from assumptions from coding
theory or super singular as a Chinese
and and other new assumptions and they
also saw a synchronous scheme which are
built from symmetric primitives
the most prominent example would be
Sphinx which is an H base signature
scheme yeah um so we asked the questions
if there are other alternative ways to
build the signature scheme also only
relying on symmetric primitives and we
base our signature scheme on two recent
progresses from from recent years one is
based on on recent work on symmetric key
primitives that only require very few
multiplications or in our context few
end gates and the other recent recent
progress we we use here is that zero
knowledge proof for generator circuits
have become practical and we we build
our signature scheme on these two
advances um so we need to want that a
primitive which are called signal
protocols these are interactive
protocols we are a approver wants to
convince a verifier that he that he
knows something and they they have this
free move form where first approver
commits to some some randomness then the
verifier sends a challenge to prove and
based on the challenge based on the
challenge to prove our sends some
response and the airfare can then verify
the statement by by using the response
and the recommitment to the randomness
they are also known as honest verifies
your knowledge proofs and and and can be
can be very useful and they allow to
build also not entire
if versions of the serial knowledge
proof we are a well-known technique by
Fiat and chammiya which is already very
old and on one hand this allows to to
get a non-interactive proof but also
allow us to get a signature scheme from
any signal protocol in in our case we we
look at a statement which is built from
a one-way function and we have used a
secret key an input and one we function
in the public key will contain the image
of the one-way function and then we use
a signal protocol to prove the knowledge
of the of the input under that function
and use the future me transform to turn
that into a signature scheme yeah so now
let's let's look at some of an example
of such in the Sigma protocol so said
Kapoor is a sigma protocol for
arithmetic circuits so any any function
you can slowly represent by a field
operations plus and plus in the
multiplication and it it is based on
Anand paradigm by issue at all which is
called MPC in the head where you perform
an MPC computation in on the prover side
and then you you'll you'll open some of
the computations and the basic idea is
the following you have some some circuit
and then you share this circuit in two
to three parts and the idea is that if
you if you have this this free part you
can always reveal two of them without
revealing any information on the secret
input then one commit
to to the evolution of this shared
circuit and and can open two of their
relations to the verifier and the
welfare can then check the consistency
of of the devolution and here every time
we have to if there's multiplication in
the circuit we have to take into account
various input from from from other
parties and so the efficiency of this
protocol heavily relies on the number of
multiplications in the circuit right so
it's a first computer contribution we've
improved set kapu to variant that we
call set KP + + + on one hand we have
carefully identified some values that we
do not need to do not need to be
transmitted to get and to to obtain the
signal protocol and also perform some
optimal optimizations where we require
in am Oracle model which we'll have to
use anyway because we yeah because we
use the future may transform and there
we have to use random Oracle's then
we've also removed many checks that were
in the original protocol but which
rendered obsolete by about our
optimizations and so we end up with we
can reduce the size of the proofs by
around half the size but don't be any
extra computation on the cost so I'm not
going to match in to the details and
what we did for the optimizations but
some of them were somewhat easier to
observations where we've just defined
very carefully how we perform the
initial secret the initial secret
sharing and use and PNG that we use
anyway we have to where we have to
publish the the seeds so we don't have
to include the inputs in in the in the
proofs and can remove some parts of of
the proof for example
but then we also have some optimizations
where we require the the random Oracle
model and particularly that we build and
and signature scheme out of it and
whenever you perform this future a new
transform you you have to you'll have to
hash the commitments that present in the
first phase and so since these
commitments that we hash here also
contained commitments already then
review this challenge that this computer
band better an Oracle as a commitment to
commitments and Kenneth remove some of
the commitments that we would have to
send otherwise yeah we do something
similar to the input to the output
shares that we did to the input yes and
can remove something can remove those
shares because we can recompute
everything and can then check the
computation was done correctly we were
just one output unit it sounds like that
but on the other hand the original
protocol had checks for every after
every multiplication that this this that
the computation was correct but we use
again years some properties of the
commitments that they are that they are
binding so unless you've computed that
correctly you so we remove all these
checks and use the binding of the
commitment to check the computation and
this saves a lot of checks in in between
then we also have another optimization
based on the random Oracle model where
in the protein the commitments during
the protocol ute if if you consider here
as HBase commitments you would always
add an extra some extra bits of
randomness
but since we our first commitment is the
seat that we use for the PNG which is
derived randomly in the beginning we
used the random Oracle to - took so that
we can reuse that this is randomness in
the commitment saving again some some
bits and bytes that we don't have to
include in the proofs and then this is
one of the other major optimizations
that saves a lot of data so if when you
verify the the circuit you'll you'll
have to recompute to two or two of those
branches and we observe that you can
recompute one of them so simply with
what you have have in the proof that you
need to recompute anyway and then again
use the binding of the commitment that
you can only recompute that correctly if
you so that we use here that the
commitment only verifies if the view was
computed correctly and so that we then
we don't need to start of you right okay
right so I mentioned that we we built
the signatures from from one way
functions here so our first construction
which we called fish in the paper which
is now picnic FS we use this set KP plus
plus and then over F as a one-way
function to build a signature scheme and
here we use the the future may transform
and this gives us improve with secure
signature scheme in a random Oracle
model but then if you consider the
future mutants transform signature
scheme in random Oracle where the cuenta
Maru 3 has so whether the random Oracle
is planned time accessible
you'll you'll have some problems the
original so the future me approves
requires rewinding and it's not clear
how to translate that into into the into
the cool room setting there's some
reasons we worked by a baiioon rule
which defined some conditions where
where you can transfer it but we our
construction does not meet those
conditions but fortunately is
transformed that is called us transform
which which helps to use a similar
technique to get a signature scheme out
of of seeking of signal protocols and
what this Unruh transformation does it
adds an extra random permutation and you
compute responses for for for some of
the possible challenges and then you add
apply the random permutation and produce
the challenge based on on the output of
the permutation and then using this
transformation we get signature scheme
which is uses again set KP plus plus and
one way function to build a proof of
secure teachers in signature scheme in
the q Rama in the paper this was called
picnic and which we now call picnic you
are for right so the only transformation
incur some some overhead
since you'll have to serialize more data
including some of the so some of the
permutations of the responses so it gets
more expensive but we could get it down
to a factor of 1.6 compared to the
original future may transform signature
scheme
yo canis is alright but we need to
select some one-way function which works
well with the set key set Kapuso has
very a very small number of
multiplications so if you look at one of
a signature that is produced from with
this technique you'll have a factor that
is influenced by the number of
multiplications and the underlying ring
or the underlying field size so you'll
have some some constants C 1 and C 2
that and C 3 that only add that depend
on the security level you want to
achieve which influenced by the size of
the commitments size of the seeds for a
pseudo-random number generator and so on
but then you have one factor that is
solely composed of the multiplication
count of the circuit so you here you're
interested in in finding a circuit from
one we function with a very small number
of multiplications but also where it's
not only a small number of
multiplication but we're also the
product of the ring size and the number
of multiplications is small alright so
we've looked into some of the one some
one-way functions that one can build
from block ciphers and in - functions
and if in so we've looked at a es e r2
r3 and all of them have a rather high
number of multiplications where you've
end up with where the product of the
field size and the number of
multiplications is over 4,000 or 5,000
or for the hedge funds and frankish
functions over 20,000 but there are some
new proposals for lightweight primitives
which all allow to reduce this product
and the best possible fit in our case
was below MC which when we can get to
for 128-bit classic security level we
can get this product below 1000 but this
is kind of very abstract so if you look
at an final signature size numbers you
you can see that if you if you look at
numbers for low MC you'll get signature
sizes which around hundred kilobytes and
for AES based or something like that
you'll get 300 kilobytes or for sure
something that is larger than one
megabyte so let's take a short look into
low EMC so this is its light weight
proxy for design which allow us to
select the parameters based on many
different parameter metric metrics so
one can parameterize in a way that you
for example minimize the number of ends
the number of ends that have to be
computed per input bit or also you can
minimize the end depth and so there's
some example of instances where each of
them minimizes one of the three matrices
for us here since this is then a binary
circuit the number of ancestors the most
important thing for optimizing the
signature sizes also one nice thing
about long C is that it it can be parama
at least currently addressed in a way
that you can select a very small data
complexity which means that in our case
an adversary only sees one plaintext
ciphertext payer but this is a very
unusual setting for a block cipher but
for low MC you'll have you have ways to
reduce the number of rounds if you if
you know that this smaller data
complexity is enough so we've looked in
two different instances for following
seeit it
at 256 and 128-bit classically security
levels and you will always get pictures
like that where you if you increase the
number of ends and that's increased the
number of the the signature size you
you'll get faster signing in
verification algorithms but paid it in
the in the signature and the signature
size and if you try to reduce the
signature size and reduce the number of
ends the linear layer of the flow MC
becomes very expensive and the runtimes
explode but you'll get smaller and
smaller signatures so we've selected
instances that it's a trade-off between
a runtime and n signature size so when
we started to to implement at the
signature schemes we already got some
good runtime numbers with around 30
milliseconds to four of for signing and
verification was a lot smaller faster
with around 17 or 16 milliseconds but
since since then we were able to
optimize these algorithms a lot more and
what we've submiss submitted now to nist
to the nice post quantum computation
achieves a lot faster signing in
verification times and almost reduced it
by 1/2 yeah right so we've also compared
it to some other recent proposals in
particular to sphinx which is the only
which is one of the the other signature
schemes which only relies on symmetric
primitives and we we've come closer to
their signing times but we we can't beat
their verification
they also achieve smaller signatures but
pay the price in this secret key in
publications and then you can look into
signature schemes which are based on
structured hardness assumptions and
there you it is the picture is a lot
you've defined signature schemes which
are good at one of all the data points
but not that all of them so you'll
either have large secret keys or public
keys but small signatures or larger
signatures but smaller keys and but at
least in those cases the run-around time
for signing in verifies verifying is
very good but in the for this latest
schemes for example the signature
generation algorithms are very slow so
at first at the first look our signature
sizes look kind of bad with around 129
kilobytes or 200 kilobytes for the only
transformed version but if you look at
this the security level which in the
NIST competition is level one which
asked for us a 64-bit post quantum
signature schemes we can get that down
to around 30 kilobytes for the future me
transform duration or 52 kilobytes for
the original version and also the
signing times go down a lot to around 2
milliseconds which which is not a lot
right um yeah and some of these
improvements were returned by one of our
students and get a parameter which who
worked on improving low MC and at the
Loeb's implementation and so present you
the low MC encryptions how this looks
like it is a very very nice structure
where you start with you add an initial
round key to the plaintext and then
you'll apply the same round sum
sometimes where you first apply an sbox
layer which doesn't operate on the full
state but just parts of it then you'll
add a linear layer where you multiply
the state with some matrix and then you
at around constant and around key which
is yeah so in our case the the important
bits are the S box with it's the only
place where where we have ends and the
other important bits are the linear
layer which is composed of the the
matrix multiplication of the state with
with the matrix and when we compute the
round key which so if you reduce the
number of S boxes you'll increase the
number of rounds so you have more matrix
multiplications which then become
expensive so one of the problems that we
face in the signature scheme is that the
input as the secret key is is shared on
Eric's freshly shared on every execution
so you can't pre compute the round keys
for example which would be an obvious
optimization if you'd use this as a
proxy for you'd recompute the round keys
and would get rid of one matrix
multiplication that you have to do on
every encryption but we can't do that
here so we are looking on
into some optimization techniques which
which we can perform without involving
the the secret key so this is a typical
run of one of the lousy runs you will
start with s with the state then apply
the S box on some part of it then you'll
have the multiplication with the with
with one of the matrices and you add the
round constant of the round key and so
what we're trying to do here is this
part of the state that is not affected
by the S box so some of those as some
part of the round key in some part of
the constant only gets effects this this
this part which is not affected by the S
box so we want to move everything that
doesn't touch the bits interesting for
the S box before the before we start all
the rounds so we remove these matrix
multiplications up as far as we can and
and then at some point we we have to to
split them in in some part that effects
what we call the nonlinear part which is
which is the part affected by the S box
and which only affects the linear part
which we can move up and so we repeat
that until every all matrix operations
that only affect the linear part are at
the beginning of the loop so we can
remove the the matrix multiplication of
the key with the with this of the key
matrix with the secret key from each
round and replace it with one matrix
multiplication in the beginning with
with some precomputed matrix
and then we only have to perform one
matrix multiplication in the beginning
using the secret key and can apply that
to the state directly before the first
round so this is for for the linear part
and for the further nonlinear part we
can do some something very similar where
we then obtain for each round similarly
looking matrix and we until this round
this matrix is a lot smaller than the
original matrices and we can combine all
those matrices into one larger one and a
multi and perform this computation also
in the beginning and then split up the
output of that matrix multiplication
into the bits that effect each level
each round of the of the encryption so
moving those matrices around leads to a
quite significant significant
performance increase from around 30
percent which so so the blue bar blue
lines in the original version without
optimization and the green rods are ten
if you use the the optimized encryption
algorithm and we can observe similar
figures for on other platforms for
example this was it it has the same
performance gains on arm right okay
so yeah let me yeah let me end with the
conclusion here so it's so with one who
presented said KP plus plus which is an
improved zero knowledge proof for for
arithmetic circuits which only is half
on it really proves only half the sized
and said keep said kaboom we were also
able to reduce the overhead from the
owner transform and presented two new
signature schemes for in in the ROM and
Coulomb right but I the first part of
the optimizations also has of course
other applications in any anywhere you
want to have for example a
non-interactive zero knowledge proof of
some circuit in a postcard setting right
yeah we've submitted this those two
signature schemes to to the nice post
partum competition but there's also a
lot of future work that can be done in
the area so the research for symmetric
primitives with a small number of
multiplications this is quite a new one
so one might think there might be
another primitive other than them see
with maybe even less multiplications
it would also one other thing that would
lead directly to Feltham is a shion's
you know our signature scheme would be
more aggressive parameter set based on
some analysis around the case where you
only see one or two plain text
ciphertext pairs since if this case is
better understood and we could reduce
the number of rounds here that loyalty
needs then we'll get an automatically
faster signature scheme and smaller
signatures right and then one
also my topic is of course some side
channel analysis of of the signature
scheme which is which basically on one
hand on online see if and if if there
are any side channel issues which would
and maybe a lick the secret key for
example right yeah thank you for
attention
[Applause]